this week there will be a bit of
planning some news and a lot of
information about remote work
[Music]
I'm planning the new year when it comes
to gold video and my challenges by
applying prevents poor performance if
you say in evening the whole day today I
revolted to exchange that article it
will be about codebook the article will
be available its pickups comes medium
publication
[Music]
let's talk about getting an immense job
usually working remotely is working on
the project and working on new sound
matters if you are communicator
if you do the work on time and if you
really deliver what you promised to be
bold work is not sitting on the beach
and doing nothing but there are also
communities there are souls crumbs and
other stuff that you have to be really
in time and given place and connect with
the computer Wi-Fi connection some
people say that it's really not because
you cannot learn from developers who are
senior developers but it depends really
on the team and the relationships
working remotely doesn't mean that you
have to be like a digital nomad he can
do it your way
it's the beginning of the year the first
week and because I was planning a lot
and also summarizing a lot I also was
interested what was the top topic that
we talked on freakos calm and
interesting the majority of that top
topics are about getting a developer job
and some of them are about success
stories and others about us about some
taylors while there's also a group of
posts about remote work and that's why I
decided to share some websites where you
can find remote work that may be helpful
if you are looking for some remote
projects the first two portals I'm
starting with these are the portals for
the remote work for freelancers but
these portals are quite selective so you
have to pass a lot of steps in order to
to create your profile pair these two
portals are all total calm and crude
code in the jority of the other portals
you start up your own own account
the example is up work you start up your
own account you fill in your profile you
take the tests whichever you want you've
got full access to your account your
profile from the beginning and also from
the beginning you are able to start
applying for the jobs upwork.com
is the combination of all disk and
Elance
so previously there were two separate
portals right now it's one a portal it's
up worldcom and that people from all
around the world when it comes to
clients but also when it comes to
developers so don't worry about bidding
the prices but simply set your price and
start applying they have different
contracts and the friend clients you can
check the client you can check the
contracts what's good about the app work
is that it's really huge this is one of
the portals that I really recommend of
course there are different opinions
about each one I will present but this
one I know quite well and I know a lot
about success stories not just only yes
for individual and developers but also
for the whole software houses the next
one is jobs dot remote if I yo you can
of course categorize here the kind of
work let's go to engineering
all of them are remote and clicking into
the offer of course equal to its details
another we work remotely we work
remotely calm it's also nice list where
you can find not just only developers
job but also other stuff but simply can
search for the keywords you get updates
when they were published of course when
you click you see the whole description
remote is the service that's really
similar and you can find here the Deaf
jobs from different language
the next one working nomads dotco slash
jobs what's important and all of these
kind of Porthos is to use categories to
search wisely faster and to save your
time this is the portal called Angel dot
Co here you will find a lot of started
jobs another service wfh dot IO the next
place we are hireable calm and one more
freelancer.com it's very often the same
offer appears on different portals some
of them aggregate the others from other
portals but also the clients were often
published the same offer on different
channels on different services at Stack
Overflow when in the current mode he can
find a lot of offers for different
languages you can also find them in code
panayo as slash jobs but here you have
to really look for remote here in the
description I want to share some lessons
I've learned that I think that can be
useful for you if you're wondering this
year to start the remote where all to
take some remote gigs if you really care
about getting a new project the best
option is to be active and to be
reactive to answer whenever your clients
rights to you responds the same thing
and if you have to write a lot of extra
stuff during the response or additional
questions to the project or some
external
please write that you will write back
tomorrow at the same time is keep the
contact live you can really rise your
status among the other candidates by
sharing by being the person who is
really searchable online I have to start
combining information that's really in
that's really important for the given
job it's important in there uncertainly
offer but it's also great if you have
current LinkedIn account if you have
some blog if you write some articles if
you share some content if you spread the
news about what you know if you have
others because this way the person with
whom you run away maybe it's simply
easily notice you're online and simply
check whether you are reliable or not
what you are saying it was often in the
journey of these portals you can also
create your account your profiles and
have your portfolio items or additional
length of your attentional resources
about you don't omit it whether the past
you can also take this test
some of them like cannot work in them in
my opinion they are very very
theoretical ones but at the same times
that some people that some clients that
look at your profile at your at your
profile and these portals really from
the top to the bottom so if you have an
empty
any references if you don't have penny
portfolio items if you don't have an
information about you about what you did
so far why do not the other person is
the best person for their project they
simply may go to the next candidate yes
it's a kind of whack it takes time to
prepare it but later you can use the
same content on the other portals
because usually their questions repeat
when preparing your profile you can do a
lot of copy and paste from LinkedIn from
other portals that you are already in
it's not the same when applying to the
authors treat clients individual don't
design from a given photo just for me
because somebody somebody from your
friends didn't have LOC there because
maybe they had a different account maybe
they have the different skills
maybe they didn't look a lot maybe they
did a poor job you should try something
on your own
[Music]
I don't want bad news for you I started
uploading my content uploading my loves
to free code scammed YouTube channel and
you can find me under the playlist a to
our blog I can reach more people and
help more people and share with more
people and in joining the courting of
free code camp is it really a price for
me thank you
next week I'll come back to react
functionality in the recipe box I keep
on doing stay motivated and develop each
day I'll see you next week
[Music]